you dare enter this house
you bad [ __ ] it's the Lord's
Day you showed up like a [ __ ] priest
pitching for a little young that get him
saying oh [ __ ] is right you bad
[ __ ] up ones over here give it
to you straight
it's a beautiful day to be alive uncle
Joey here you bad [ __ ]
it's like June 11 we're making progress
[ __ ] will creep it up on these
[ __ ] creeping while you're
sleeping but besides that it's the
Lord's Day you understand me
Jesus died for your sin designed for you
to [ __ ] die for your own sins you
[ __ ] miserable [ __ ] grab your
balls write your goals it's gonna be a
[ __ ] phenomenal phenomenal week how
do I know that cuz I [ __ ] know that's
the first let you being a notebook it's
gonna be a [ __ ] tremendous weekend as
a matter of fact it's a beautiful day to
be alive
there ain't a [ __ ] clouds everywhere
the sun's not out but the love in my
nutsack is ready to spread wisdom all
over you [ __ ] you understand me
and that's what Sunday's are about
remember on the seventh day God created
Black Sabbath today is the seventh
[ __ ] day today this is when you put
your [ __ ] mind to work with everybody
else's at the beach hahahaha right there
at the hotel
Oh get the [ __ ] out of here you're
playing games but you're also thinking
defense I mean do you understand me
you're thinking about the weekend how're
you gonna put it together forget the
future if you get 2028 the Olympics are
coming I don't give a [ __ ] I'm worried
about [ __ ] Sunday the 11th of June
and how we're gonna put this envelope
together today you understand me because
we live for today tomorrow
who gives a [ __ ] we might get hit with a
meteor or I will [ __ ] sleep in that
one all that [ __ ] philosophize and
from monday goes out the [ __ ] window
sunday you put it down you understand me
sunday you write your goal sunday you
said yourself this is the week when I
[ __ ] them breakthrough ain't nobody
gonna give me [ __ ] this week that's what
Sunday's are about that's why they
called the [ __ ] Lord's Day give me a
minute [ __ ] but Joey what's with the
[ __ ] beat and I hope things spark
that [ __ ] number enough is enough
you're absolutely right
I got some tremendous tweets today
I got [ __ ] diamond D understand this
[ __ ] oh my god tomorrow we make the
pickup on the one I jus he says he's got
some [ __ ] but so there's you smoke it
you want to [ __ ] do jumping jacks
that's how good that is but enough is
enough with your life you gotta get your
life by the [ __ ] horns and say you
know what the [ __ ] ends here today
I'm the [ __ ] Captain Kirk this [ __ ]
Enterprise right and that's what I do on
a date I don't give a [ __ ] about half
these [ __ ] [ __ ] you see
people around me you see I don't need
this [ __ ] my life I came out of a room
solo once that cut that umbilical cord
you gotta realize you're in this world
on your own
you understand me what that means is you
gotta get up every [ __ ] day with a
[ __ ] savagery in your heart if you're
one of these [ __ ] that giggles did
you see South Park here keep keep keep
giggling you [ __ ] wait till Isis
function the ass with no Vaseline II
understand
there you go that [ __ ] smoke all the
way back to the cerebrum with my soul
understand me as the type of weed I'm
smoking too you know why cuz I'm just
like you I'm looking for [ __ ] answers
and when you smoke this weed you give
yourself the answers you're looking for
because you know the answers to your
life everybody's always looking for
counselling and let's get the [ __ ] out
of here
you know why they call it the ID tone
[ __ ] and the iPod because I you got the
answers to your [ __ ] questions and
you don't even know it
you sit there over there I don't want to
answer those questions cuz I'm gonna
scare myself scare yourself you ain't
living til you're walking around [ __ ]
scared you think I eat any [ __ ]
edibles every day cuz I won't walk
around like a Vietnam vet ready to
explode you follow me did some right
this morning at the coffee shop I'm
gonna plum ID and go for a little Sunday
jujitsu it's a light class today fool
little [ __ ] drills gotta burn some of
this [ __ ] fat off my stomach the hard
[ __ ] nothing's working
listen god only gives you a certain
amount of [ __ ] ticks til I write a
couple had enough beats I [ __ ] it up I
did blow all those years I accelerated
the heartbeats so I could drop dead any
[ __ ] day so every day I walk around I
swing pick with three heads I don't give
a [ __ ] cuz the end is nailed 54 is the
downhill smoke so I gotta go out every
day like a [ __ ] honey mommy you
understand me and I suggest you do the
same because if I would have done this
at 28 or 32 I'd be unstoppable right now
you understand and be over that blowing
[ __ ] missiles the careers shooting
back at them take that you [ __ ]
TransAm me that anyway you know I love
you [ __ ] Thursday night the Ice
House I'm working it out but at the same
problems you got I'm working it out I'm
trying to get material to shoot a new
special so any gel $10 on a Thursday
night you come down we smoke some reefer
it's the ice house
yeah and I live by 10 o'clock who's
better than you and you got to hang out
with Joey Lee always be there you don't
leave my [ __ ] room on each of life
he's down not next week isn't the party
starts next week I don't listen I don't
do tours or nothing I'm on the poorer
[ __ ] life giving hard and [ __ ]
given attitude that's my [ __ ] tour I
like daily but next week the tour that
starts in [ __ ] Long Island in levee
town and governor is the 24th and 25th
for the 23rd and I don't [ __ ] know
date so I'm gonna [ __ ] calendar to
you you ready for another one that's
doing the long as well off we got e on
the agenda
this is the diamond perennial it's like
[ __ ] candy cane sugar you understand
you ever get from them candy canes
whatever candy can't [ __ ] yeah I
don't man who gives a [ __ ] they both
make you fat
let's smoke some [ __ ] week
there's his Sunday [ __ ] you gotta get
a jump on the Lord
oh yeah oh yeah listen I don't do this
to be fun
I do this because it's a family we get
together on Sundays we discuss our
little [ __ ] problems I'll let you
know what's on the table and now you
know you're not like them you know out
of the [ __ ] cold with Joey there's no
Joe ain't doing dick this week Joey's
doing the same thing your mother [ __ ]
doing which is slaying dick and going to
be the best it could be this route
actually I don't want to be a
millionaire I'm gonna [ __ ] have a
yacht I don't want to [ __ ] hang out
with snow I don't have a nobody it's
what I have with you people regular
[ __ ] people we put our pants on one
leg at a time like the rest of these
[ __ ] but they think they're
better than you go [ __ ] yourself I'm the
one that's got nothing [ __ ] cereal in
the morning like a savage getting ready
to [ __ ] gone don't forget
Philadelphia you know I love you
[ __ ] you're my backbone I ran
down there four years when I was a kid
from Glassboro when it was but Rowan
when it was Glassboro the [ __ ] Camden
to Pennsauken I'm telling you right now
the ball got a July 20 night his way you
gotta beat me I'm saying whether you
want to be there or not you better
[ __ ] be there I'm showing up with
chicken cutlets creamed corn and
cranberry juice a little club soda and
that's what it's all about when you're
living in Jersey but that's July 29th
I'm not worried about you likely I have
to worry about [ __ ] June 11th and now
we're gonna take over [ __ ] world are
you gonna take over your life and tell
these [ __ ]
you're not playing games no more you
understand me so get that bowl of that
life write it write your goals get you a
week ready because this week we're gonna
have to shoot your leg [ __ ] I know chop
all you understand this is the week that
killed Greg Walden I'm off and running
out of [ __ ] to do and people to see
don't forget that night seven o'clock
the Church of what's happened now Lord's
Day edition so you got it nice and early
Monday morning and Thursday night boom
the ice out of ten bucks
eight o'clock no [ __ ] around Pasadena
I suggest you write your goals today
have a great dinner with your family hug
the people that love you
Jeff you're not the rest of these
[ __ ] you ain't outwit and we have
you're in jail I gotta bail ya know they
gotta hang up on you tire store what did
you do
why would you do that shut the [ __ ] up
bail me out [ __ ] if then I gotta bail
you out
get him out of the way on face of
unfriend them on Facebook and go on with
your life and Sunday mother [ __ ]
uncle Joey see you [ __ ] tonight
seven o'clock be ready at Rock tonight
we'll then we'll go on beep tonight
we're going overdosing tonight
and beside that you know I love your
mother [ __ ] without you I wouldn't
have dick that's one thing I don know
funny [ __ ] guy I just tell you how it
is my Tiger Woods in my [ __ ] heart
okay that's what makes me different
lolly [ __ ] then it's you and uncle Joey
Tilly and I'm with you you're with me
and they want to be with us stay black
to the church tonight seven Ice House
[ __ ] nah Thursday and the following
week Friday inside a levee town like a
[ __ ] go out there spring dick if
they don't believe you just shove your
dick down their [ __ ] crump don't
understand what I mean with your saying
I love you [ __ ] have a good day
love your family hug the cat and that's
it and that's that my wife a lot being
outside oh yeah they get oliva they
didn't get my mic that don't let daily
stay back